Apple's M3 MacBook gear is gonna be
absolutely insane in terms of
performance so fast that it's going to
be faster than the M2 Pro chip and the
base 14 inch MacBook Pro and if you
don't believe me I'll prove it to you in
this video so if you're thinking about
picking up the 14 inch pro you might
just want to hold off now before I jump
into all the math using the new huge
leak of the a17 bionic chips performance
you need to understand the relationship
between Apple's a series iPhone chips
and M series Mac chips when the M1 chip
was released we quickly discovered that
it packs CPU and GPU cores that came
directly from the A14 iPhone chip with
them being basically identical now of
course the M1 added a bunch of other
stuff in there as well but the cores
themselves were the same and that's what
translates to the performance we see in
benchmarks like geekbench 6. the only
difference is that for some reason this
single core performance of the ab ships
are always higher than the hips that
they were based on for example the
single core performance of the M1 is
actually 13.7 percent higher than the
A14 even though the cores themselves are
identical why well because apple is
clocking those cores higher in the M1
chip 3.2 gigahertz on the Mac instead of
3.0 on the iPhone and iPad and same for
the relationship between the M2 Chip and
the a15 that it was based on the M2 was
clocked at 3.5 instead of 3.2 on the a15
leading to a single core score that's
16.3 percent faster even though the
cores themselves are basically the same
so what I'm going to do is take those
numbers and apply them to the
relationship between the upcoming a17
Bionic chip and of course the M3 Mac
champ and if you're wondering why I'm
completely ignoring scoring the a16 ship
is because it doesn't actually matter to
the M3 chip at all it's already been
confirmed that even though they're
calling it a four nanometer chip it's
really just third gen 5 nanometer with
no legible technical differences
compared to second gen 5 nanometer but
the biggest reason is that it's already
been confirmed that both the a17 and M3
chips will be built using tsmc's brand
new three nanometer chip lithography
process which means that they'll Shear
this same exact cores just like what
happened to the A14 and M1 as well as
the a15 and M2 and yes this means that
the a16 chip is being completely skipped
and forgotten when it comes to its
impact on the mship series because if
you didn't already figure out Apple's
release cycle strategy we get an eight
ship every single year in September
while we only get a new mship every 1
1.5 years so every now and then an eight
ship must be completely skipped and
that's happening this year with the M3
chip being based on the a17 instead of a
16. and now let's get into the math a
couple of weeks ago Tech Reeve on
Twitter shared leaked a17 Bionic chip
benchmarks from a Korean website and
they actually make a lot of sense when
comparing them to the a16 and by the way
we're going to be using geekbench 6
exclusively for this video since it's
been redesigned to be more realistic
than ever before as you can see the a17
scores 3019 points in the single core
test and
7860 in multi-core so to figure out the
performance of the M3 chip all we have
to do is apply the percentage gains that
we calculated earlier in this video when
going from the A14 chip to the M1 and
the a15 chip up to the M2 and of course
apply that to the M3 and since we got an
average gain of the amp chip being 15
faster than the respective eight ship
all we've got to do is add 15 to the
single core score of the leaked a17 and
we end up with an estimate of
3472 points for the M3 chip making it
the fastest stock chip in the world
surpassing the record holding Intel I9
13900ks by about 13 and then in apple
silicon terms that score is actually
about 32 percent faster than the M2 a
huge gen over gen Improvement which will
lead to snap your web browsing and
Common App performance however one thing
to know is that the a17 chip is rumored
to come with eight gigs of RAM instead
of the previous six which gives an
advantage to geekman's scores but the M3
chip will likely get the same 8 gigs of
RAM as before so the numbers might be a
bit lower than these calculations just
keep that in mind now moving on to
multi-core Performance the M1 chip was
about 69.5 faster than the A14 while the
M2 Chip was 78.5 faster than the a15 and
those two numbers give us an average of
74 faster so if we take the
7860 score from the a17 leak and add 74
on top we get 13
676 multi-core points for the M3 chip
making it a massive 41.5 faster than the
M2 but here's something that some of you
might not have expected that 13
676 score officially makes the M3 chip
13.8 faster than the bend 10 core M2 Pro
chip which is kind of insane because
that wasn't the case with the M2 Chip at
all which was still behind the older M1
Pro chat now in terms of the unbend 12
core M2 Pro that model is still going to
be faster than the M3 with scores above
000 but it's honestly not that big of a
difference and yes I actually do believe
that the M3 chip will be that fast since
the three nanometer and three chip
family will be a huge advancement over
the M2 which was basically just an
overclocked stop Gap chip so essentially
the M3 MacBook Air will be faster than
the base model 14-inch MacBook Pro and
both single core and multi-core so if
you're thinking about buying that 14
inch model right now it could be a good
idea to hold off and wait however the 14
inch pro will still have features that
you can't get on the M3 air like a 120
hertz Pro motion display all of the
extra ports like HD Mi SD card
additional Thunderbolt the Dual fans the
larger display bigger battery
Etc so if you want any of those features
you've still got to go up to the 14 inch
which is why it still makes sense in the
lineup and keep in mind that the 13-inch
air will likely still only come with
eight gigs of Base RAM and a 256 gig SSD
half of what the 14 inch includes at the
base price so buyers will still be
trying to figure out which one to buy
based on their needs even though the M3
air will likely be faster but the secret
weapon of the M3 air will be the new
additional 15-inch model which is going
to be super appealing to a lot of people
who previously purchased the Pro Models
just because of the larger display now
as far as the GPU performance we still
don't have any leaks of the a17 chips
Graphics so there's really no way to
estimate the performance of the M3 chip
but one thing we do know is that Apple
was worth on a completely new GPU design
that was meant for the a16 bionic chip
but it had some flaws so Apple reverted
back to the old a15 chips GPU and yes I
mean that literally because the dye
analysis shots of both a15 and 16 chips
proven so essentially we can expect a
brand new GPU core design for the a17
chip built on three nanometer and
apparently with Hardware Ray tracing
support built in and of course since the
a17 and M3 chips will share the same
exact cores this means that the M3 will
be getting them as well so it's going to
be a graphics beast and on top of that
we can also expect new faster versions
of the media engine encoders and
decoders which will be helpful for
anyone working with video footage and as
far as the release date I personally
don't think the M3 chip will be released
until this fall but who knows maybe it's
going to come at WWDC like some others
are guessing so with that said if this
video made you excited about the new M3
chip comment down below and click that
Circle about to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign